okay four people joining this livestream
we are talking about incremental
language development for from language
this is a series of meetings which we've
been having as it seems from the first
item on our agenda for five years now
and it's delivered many many important
features of often language we'd actually
stopped these meetings for a short while
because we just finished version 12.1
and we'd not been focusing on on new
designs for a little bit but we are
restarting and even in these pandemic
times we are steaming ahead so let's
take a look at some okay this seems to
be a summary of things that are in the
aisle the area um so these are things
that are moving on right now and could
discuss a bit of priorities okay all
right um hey you know it we're really
good to solve the the whooshing problem
of microphone whooshing problem but any
case um alright and actually hold on one
second I have to solve a small problem
here just a second um
you
hi um okay fold while fold well list
okay
is that a comp I mean yeah go ahead this
is a function which is almost done it we
are just reviewing the last two
arguments which are the arguments that
handle
how many more elements of less you get
right okay
echo timing so do we have a design for
what echo timing is going to generate as
output and another question about that
so you know I end up finding that I do
copy/paste of echo cells from notebooks
and to two things there that we should
probably think about one is what happens
when you copy paste an echo cell and the
other is what happens when you do a
notebook import when you have echo cells
in the notebook both of these seem to be
okay but I'm just not completely sure
that we've got it exactly right and for
echo timing I can see the same type of
thing that is um if we are trying to
let's just do an echo here um okay so
now I do a copy paste here um the UM
you know what am i copying here and
where does it copy to does that copy
that copies like that if I copy the
whole cell I mean I'm just confused here
okay but one thing that definitely
doesn't work let me show you something
that definitely is pretty ugly um if I
say parallel valuate here oh god it's
going to launch all of my compute nodes
here um okay this is about to be pretty
ugly and I don't know exactly what how
it's transporting from the parallel
kernels the echo cells ASIS
I mean that's what I get for having I
think I've got 93 cause right now I
could well it makes it means that when I
do a computation it's about a hundred
times faster than it would otherwise be
which is quite useful okay look at this
see that greater than greater than sign
that's really ugly
right this message you've seen what we
use in the terminal right and I I you
know be better if there was some I don't
know how this is being transported if we
could look at that that'd be great um
and clearly when we do a copy of this
we're getting some ugly string type
thing that's we oh that was a copy of a
cell but let's see what happens if I do
that now I will just get a string copy
right yeah that's really ugly
so that would be nice to avoid at the
very least let's just send through a
Unicode character there but it still
would be better I mean be better than
not having at all
or if we could if we have to do it in
some hacky way there we could send
through a Unicode character that that
disappears on evaluation or something
anyway this is a minor corner case I
just point this out um okay do we in
fact have a styling for echo timing or
not yet I think we do we are adding it
right now so I think next week we will
be able to finish this and there's a
pull request open to add this it's like
a truck okay don't make it too heavy
I mean we really don't need a giant you
know grandfather clock image or
something I mean just a very very light
thing like that good okay fine nothing
too cutesy um Jose you should get
somebody to help you debug your your
wind noise thing I don't know if I knew
more about audio engineering I'd be able
to tell you what it is it's some kind of
game thing or something um okay ah okay
attach coordinates partial code below
yes so this is a function that takes an
array of values and a range of
coordinates and it would return yeah a
little useful function right yeah
and we will do these four numbers
quantities states and multiple other
things good right okay
hair applied head mapped this whole
thing right I mean again yeah I mean
that's primarily a naming problem right
which is okay well we just we just
surveying what we're doing here so
okay extract with the fault yes this is
another thing we started to discuss in
the last meeting and the problem is that
we don't want to follow the precedent of
first by adding whole trust because that
would spoil the second or third argument
yes well unless we just evaluate them
unless we have a nominal whole dress but
just evaluate them yes we could be
strange I think yeah I would prefer if
we don't have that okay all right so
listen for purposes what we're trying to
achieve right now the let's just survey
this quickly and we're deciding which
things here involve design discussion
which things here involves something
else
okay splice for multiple heads I really
would like to see this happen the splice
table thing I was talking to Roger about
that yesterday about the issue of of
essentially switching off a list ability
for symbolic vectors which is kind of
the inverse of splice ability not the
inverse the the the negation of splice
ability so I think that's a topic we
need to discuss is splice ability and
essentially wrapping lists to prevent
list ability makes sense
okay well so let's keep going with your
survey list here um
so this is another big discussion that
we had a few meetings ago and so here
we're going to have these new functions
and it's not clear whether we want to go
this column functions or Idina single
speck look I mean my basic point of view
here is data set is very powerful but
comparatively hard to use the question
is what can we do to make you know I
think we need to kind of zoom out a bit
and think about what do we need to do to
make data set easier to use and this may
well it wind up you know dovetailing
with that as we build things which are
for example natural language input forms
or a lot of autosuggest forms for
queries and so on I think this will
dovetail with that does that make sense
or am i off in the wrong direction here
yes so data sets certainly will offer a
new point of view yes I think we will
still have the issue of what to do with
structures like extract data set no I
understand that but I mean I think the
question is whether we need to signal
the word with the word column a bunch of
separate operations like column total
and things like this maybe we do I mean
they're common enough that maybe they're
worth doing but I think if we do that it
needs to you know column total certainly
needs to work on a data set and maybe we
will learn something from trying to do
the more general design for data set so
but I think that's a you know if you're
asking is this something we should be
covering an ILD the answer is obviously
yes and that's a um but you know that
seems like a fairly complicated
discussion it is we have had that
discussion a couple of times already and
it's I mean this is this is always um
you know this is a design heavy
discussion I mean everything we're
seeing so far as design heavy not
particularly implementation heavy
okay uncertainty yes so here there are
three directions in which we want to go
one is step setting up around objects
because they can be given in various
ways and for this we need a thinking
around form function following what we
do with quantity quantity form or with
numbers with number form what are we
doing but do we even have a quantity
form and did we did we do oh my gosh I'm
sure we designed it here
yeah it's not used a lot but there are
cases where you may want to print it out
with the full unit name instead of the
short form or you may want both of them
essentially you know I want to comment
on something about that I I'm I mean
I'm finding a bunch of these things if I
type in six meters for example here and
I get this I don't know I mean this this
form
but actually this isn't the case I'm
really complaining about let me let me
type in mass of the earth
that that did didn't do what I was
expecting it to do okay here's an
example like Planck mass okay that's
pretty weird
I mean like the one
is pretty weird the fact that I mean I
guess M sub P actually here's a worst
case okay that's crazy
the fact that it says one time see why
does it do that why isn't it just C so
we have so you can see in the in the
control equals pot it just shows up as C
and that's because we have a general
typeset form for physical constants that
when they come back parsed we basically
know that you want a single value of
them we still haven't generalized that
type setting for all instances where you
have a one value you because we don't
have an up it there's an implementation
element of it and there's basically a
general design question of do we want to
just say one times any physical constant
always just shows up as the physical
constants my vision I think we do well
the abbreviation is a kind of weird
because you know if I'm saying
um you know e equals you know m and then
I want to say I don't know what happens
if I just say C here doesn't I wonder
whether I get offered okay so unit it's
kind of a weird thing here that's
probably the speed of light right yeah
that's a weird even calling it a unit
there is kind of wrong then I do that
okay that's really a lose yeah I'm
pretty unhappy with that and I don't
even know what this means with that I
mean that's distinctly bad that we treat
constants through the quantity framework
and so we treat them as units and so I
mean you can say twice the speed of
light which is nice sure and we want
that
I mean 0.8 C or something is something
we want but I'm just saying purely as a
typesetting matter we don't want this we
don't want the parens and we don't want
the one see what I'm saying yeah we've
done some work like in the formula data
framework to try and clean some of these
up for common formulas but I do think
basically what I need to do is work with
Eric and have some sort of internal
market
to differentiate physical constants from
general unay let's do it now that's get
this let's get this cleaned up okay I
mean I'm also concerned that
um oh that's funny that was that he
isn't be I thought it was um I guess I'm
also concerned
[Music]
there are cases which I found that a
much more bizarre than this I mean the
sea is a little weird that you just get
back a thing to see that's sitting there
but there's another there's some other
cases that are much stranger where I'm
I'm let's see if I if I get um um what's
a good example where I just get back
something that is some quite obscure
abbreviation
that I would rarely actually abbreviate
in practice
um gosh what's a good example well let's
say Hubbell time
you
I guess it's okay I mean I guess
whatever you know it's a it's a notation
for that um I guess it's alright to put
it out in that form I think I've had
some slightly stranger examples of this
definitely we definitely do not want to
evaluate this okay yeah there's another
issue here which is when I say unit
convert okay so fine that goes two
seconds but but there are lot of cases
where I've got well okay so let's
imagine I've got you know the Hubble
time divided by C squared or something
oops um Hubble time divided by C squared
okay so I have that slightly strange
formula the question is when if I say
2.7 times that okay I probably want
that's fine
you know unit convert is a slightly
strange thing to say to get that
evaluated oh yeah yeah the other issue
is oh yes yes this is the other assumed
the other issue is when do I get so
let's say I say um five miles per hour
okay I mean first of all that's pretty
odd mi /h is pretty odd but fine I can
live with that let's go seven meters per
second okay and let's say percent the
read about percent percent
Oh actually did the right thing
what happens though if I have non
commensurate units here so if I have
something where I'm going I mean one of
the annoying things is that I might have
five miles per hour divided by six
meters
and then there's a question of what
units I end up getting um
that either um okay actually two
interesting comments on our live stream
here first comment is n a percent twenty
nine and of the speed of light
yeah that's a complicated story because
I can absolutely imagine saying 2/3 the
speed of light and being quite annoyed
that you know I mean numerical
evaluation is sort of a different story
from evaluation of the constant and I
mean unit convert is basically going to
base units right right by default if you
don't specify target it will go to the
SI base units right
what does it do like for if I say
you
you
oh gosh
I mean correct but rather weird yeah
temperature is a complicated case that
we're looking at a larger design
discussion about differentiating
different use cases for but in general
[Music]
for in an absolute temperature the base
unit associated with it is Kelvin so
yeah right look the issue here is for
these physical constants and so on you
know I think n the mission of n is
numerical evaluation and okay you might
argue why is it the case this is a very
philosophical discussion that n of pi
turns into that but n of C does not
gosh the the the scary thing about this
is with the whole new physics theory we
actually could do hi yeah I mean it
actually kind of makes it seem like the
sea is closer to a pie then to something
else but I think it's odd to you know
okay
the argument is why should NF PI
evaluate
because it is going to give a number but
NFC which could give a United quantity
see the thing is that most unit
quantities if I say something like um
you know density of osmium or something
because these are measured quantities
basically they are always numerical
but in a sense they are never numerical
it's just that you are converted into a
different quantity in this case grams
per centimeter cubed centimeter so it's
not a matter of numerous sizing it's a
matter of choosing a better unit well
here's an argument it could be the case
that you know let's say the density of
gold could be a fundamental you know
could be something that in our unit
system well that yeah mercury for
example in millimeters of mercury right
effectively the density of mercury is
something like a unit
we could imagine wanting to carry around
density of mercury as a symbolic object
without converting it to inter whatever
it is thirteen point six right I'm
forgetting it's thirteen point six grams
per CC isn't it let's check that that
neuron is still alive oh really I'm sure
it was thirteen point six back in the
day maybe it's a different temperature
and pressure okay in any case um but but
I mean the whole point is we're not
carrying this around symbolically it's
different from speed of light which we
are carrying around symbolically
see what I'm saying and I could imagine
something where there is a computed
thing which is well lately what do we do
for the Bohr radius
oh gosh we just do that but you know for
example how would I get the pore radius
expressed in terms of H bar you know M
sub e and so on for that you need to use
the entity physical constant s in this
column
so all these constants have an ax
corresponding entity and the entity
knows lots of relations with other
customs okay so this is the sort of
thing that Michael was working on last
year two years ago when there was a
change well I think we should okay let's
set up a separate meeting to discuss
this I mean I think there's a there's a
bunch of issues here I mean that is
there's you know there's there's three
levels here one is we just evaluate the
density of mercury to a numb you know a
quantity second we carry around the
speed of light symbolically third we
have the Bohr radius which can be
represented as it's sort of sourced
symbolic form but it can also be
represented you know like if I were to
say you know it'd be very weird but if I
were to say function expand of that I
might expect to get um you know
something in terms of H bar and so on
although function expand is kind of a
weird name just like unit converters a
weird name to go from this you know
combination I mean if I if I take this
thing here divided by the speed of light
right how do I get um you know so now I
want to convert that if I say unit
convert of that what's it going to do
it's going to give me base units
that's a weird quantity that's like
that's like the electron charge it's
really weird I didn't know would come
out like that um right now I just for my
utter confusion let me just dumb
electron charges like ten to the minus
nineteen coulombs isn't it
you
okay
okay so that's a little weird so now I
would have to say unit convert
oh goodness frigging sake okay great now
how do I get it in coulombs
you need simplified perhaps I didn't
even know we had that I have obviously
not been using these things enough you
are absolutely correct yeah I mean I
could imagine I don't know if it'll be
for unit converter unit simplify but
having I guess natural units would be a
bad name for it but sort of a canonical
value because a lot of units have sort
of their fundamental base value in Si
and then they also have sort of a
natural definition form and we don't
have an easy way to access that form
currently in the language what do you
mean
you mean like seconds and per seconds
which I know this is also wrong this
shouldn't be s times a it should be a s
shouldn't isn't that the SI convention
yeah I mean there there's some
complications with typesetting and I
know you mentioned we should probably
have a separate meeting to dive into
this a little more so if I want to get
to soccer it all right fine but let's
you know let's make sure this is in the
notes from this and let's separately
discuss this
um the can also do cool in the second
argument to unit convert I'm well aware
but I don't want to have to do that and
I mean you know like like if I say let's
try doing something like this if I say
viscosity viscosity of let's taste
something a little bit obscure let's say
benzene just because I don't want to do
something trivial okay so that second
Pascal's but that's not in poises right
so if I say unit simplify am I going to
get that incentive poised no I'm not I
don't know why um
the okay well any case um yeah with
another another discussion on this stuff
okay a couple of comments in the live
stream I want to look at one is Sammy
here to commenting on a way of entering
six plus or minus one yeah this was a
huge discussion when we built around um
you know what is the in fix form of
around what did we do finally with with
a if we'd say escape plus minus that
gives something different right we we
agreed not to use that for a round
because we think plus minus is an
algebraic plus or minus which is
different from the uncertainty plus or
minus it's what it's something that we
have there for the user to use I mean in
chess for example they use also plus
minus notation so that's minus doesn't
have any meaning yeah so locate fair
enough but I mean the question is is
there some useful is this a more
convenient way to enter in a round form
than typing around do we have an infix
form for around I think that people have
suggested is that good idea yeah yes
notice it because when we have their one
point zero we don't really know whether
that's one point zero or it's one point
zero two three can I ask a question
would it be completely crazy I mean in
other words is around popular enough
that it would be worth trying to create
an infix form for it and the in fixed
form I could imagine with something like
plus dot minus which I believe is
unambiguous
could be but doing this without an
escape without an escape I mean I think
it's a I mean I don't know we have to
you know it's a popularity contest
basically um Brian our live stream is
suggesting at plus minus is that
unambiguous don't think that's
unambiguous F at plus minus X I think is
possible yeah it is sorry um I mean we
could certainly have an escape form of
this as well but I think we could I mean
you know should we consider this as a
non escape to n fix form I mean this
requires probably yeah um there's a
question on the live stream which I
don't know the answer to but what
happens with this what is natural
language input to that ooh interesting
hmm that's interesting
different team and the one that's on the
call here um what should 6 plus minus 1
do in natural language input should it
give an assuming
probably it should yeah I think so
so that's that's something we should
feed to the natural language
understanding folk good point thank you
for that suggestion Ben um okay uh all
right let's let's continue here um okay
a round form so do we have a design for
a round form it's the things that are
needed here are first the discussion of
how many digits to show people have that
second confidence levels because when we
say plus minus 1 that means one level
one confidence level 1 Sigma people
sometimes wants 2 Sigma 3 Sigma oh I
don't know does it really mean 1 Sigma I
mean it means the thing that is in the
calculus of around I mean do we are we
really in a position to tell them what
the 2 Sigma I mean you know clearly the
actual probability distribution is
getting smashed around as we you know
propagate the around through different
different operations an approximation
that this has been approximated by a
Gaussian
but I mean is it the case that given 1
Sigma that we can compute what the 2
Sigma level is just as an algebraic
multiple of the 1 Sigma value I mean is
it literally 2 times this this one Sigma
I mean is it is the 2 sigma version of 6
plus or minus 1 6 plus or minus 2 yes
but you have to Sigma to indicate that
all you have to say something like 95%
CL or something exactly yes I see so
people want basically to display how
will this work with our actual official
probability distributions where we
really can give genuine confidence level
in the intervals yes our own form will
take an option that says
in various forms give me 93% or give me
something and then we give their
plus/minus with the correct number and
impertinence in parentheses and the
superset
yeah I understand that but I'm saying if
we actually compute it from I mean if I
were to compute I don't even know how to
do it here but if I if I have an actual
normal that let me pick a some slightly
weird distribution I don't know a
Weibull distribution um and to two
parameters okay to one okay great so now
here I should be able to say what is the
actual thing can i type confidence level
ok is that the right thing
confidence range I don't actually know
how not what is the right thing to
compute here well I guess it would be
CDF with some value I see okay fine
okay so the CDF of this with value no
but that's not what I want because
that's that's in okay but in any case
there's a there's a definite I mean my
question is given that we're actually
computing from an actual distribution we
can give an accurate you know
ninety-three percent confidence interval
to this and the question is when will we
want to use that display form to
represent that I mean the display form
you're proposing is an elaborate display
form specific to our I guess I mean the
issue is when would a thing like this
return around if you're characterizing
this distribution okay is there any way
for me to get given that given if I say
a round of normal distribution you know
of you know three comma point four then
I will get a beautiful around there
right if I say Weibull distribution a
round of a Weibull distribution oh my
gosh that's amazing
cool so what is doing is it's computing
the mean and then something that is a
description of an asymmetry
that's really cool okay I mean like now
now that I'm seeing this I'm remembering
we discussed this um what does it do for
a discrete distribution does it work
there - no okay um yeah it's less clear
what you should do in a case like this
okay well cool I mean that removes my
objection because then you can use a
round form just fine with a Weibull
distribution and give get a reasonable
result okay Steve on our live stream is
noting that around is still marked as
experimental in the 12.1 documentation
at some point it's time to promote it
okay well I mean the other issue with it
is supporting around in more places
particularly in the fitting function
statistics other places like that that's
what what is happening with that is the
statistics team working on that or who's
who's supposed to be doing that yeah it
should be them I think they're at the
moment too busy with statistics at some
point they should be okay okay um around
value so this imitate state value and
give ya is a bit of the opposite given a
round object compute many things from it
such as such as the central values such
as whatever right for example right now
we can compute some of them like an
approximated number approximate interval
etc with a method just by adding a sub
value string at the end but what happens
if you want to do is with an array of
many of them function - I see so the
analog of sort of an entity value type
thing so for this what what are the
string values their own there right
there okay so for example uncertainty
here will just give us one
okay fair enough and so the issue is to
get a function version of this sounds
reasonable okay what is this horror
about handling non-linearity right so
the formulas for propagation of errors
are using linear approximations and a
wrong replace already has a second
argument in which you can increase the
propagation order to two or three and I
have formulas up to four but people want
to use this in really really nonlinear
situations like we have backs
complaining about or around doesn't work
in the jump of a theta function I don't
even know what to do there okay well
let's take a look at what the issue is
okay so we've got a unit step for
example and we say let's let's take a
let's take the okay great there's our
unit step alright so now let's
understand what the around computation
that people want to do is yeah so you
have a round - okay
0 plus -5 and now I want to feed that
into a unit step to do this correctly
and and you see the univariate case
could work because we can do effectively
what our pneumatics is doing which is
using some sort of interval computation
what we think the answer is supposed to
be here well we users want something
like 0.599 plus minus 0.5 really why
because they know that the actual values
are me - so what happens if I do
sine of around 10 to the 10 plus minus
0.2 is that going to work it's good it's
going to do something because in this
case probably you are in some random
point of sign this gets problematic if
you do for example do around
okay that's obviously wrong right look
that's obviously wrong
so the question is what is the because
that's using linear propagation or as a
quadratic propagation or something of
errors right now how would I do this to
second order can I do the same the same
thing to second order place okay so if I
say around replace solve sine X and then
X goes to just what I want to do yep and
then the surround here and then what do
i do how do i specify the order okay
it's the formulas give it's just try to
increase it to three I doubt it well I
think it'll go worse I think it's a non
convergent story here but I mean so the
question is you know we can't in fact
okay so we know a constraint in this
case that sign has to be between plus
minus 1 at least assuming that the
around is on the real line which is what
we're always assuming right so the
question is is there any way to
propagate in function domain constraints
so to speak yes and I think we can do
better here but how well effectively by
doing an interval computation by making
sure that the wrap so the interval
computation is always the worst case
scenario so is doing it but that is
assuming what would you do you take the
one Sigma or the the plus minus values
and you would do the interval
computation for the plus minus values
and use that is not the right answer
because I mean that's assuming basically
that it's a you know a a square wave
whatever you know a you know some some
kind of square wave distribution right
which just has goes out to the to the
plus minus values and then goes to zero
out the PDF goes to zero
outside of that right yes but sorry I
said it wrong it's not Sigma it'll be
like effectively X plus minus infinity
and the sign would say oh you are it
between minus 1/m so it would it would
puff out the actual interval to be the
infinite interval and then say given
that so that will work for sine and I
mean these functions that have finite I
always forget range right the target so
these functions with finite range you
could say that is the range of the
function don't we have a function range
don't we know symbolically what the
range of those functions is yes if
nothing system already it's certainly
something that okay but so the point
then is what you're saying is for those
functions we could bound and we have
have we talked to the Rogers algebra
people about this do they have an idea
what we could do I mean is what you're
describing is okay how would you know
you're in trouble so to speak because
most of the time you don't want to be
messing around doing some weird
algebraic computation about the possible
limits of the function you just want to
be following the error propagation
formulas right so how would you know
you're in trouble well there are two
possibilities one is to do an fast
American computation because they're our
pneumatics also has error control so
that could give an indication the other
one is by realizing that we are getting
too small values for derivatives
compared to what an average derivative
is for that function explain that one to
me I mean so in this case here what we
have I mean what happened here I mean
clearly that one we can tell something
went wrong right yes but for example
another case is having sine around a
horizontal point mm-hmm because the
derivatives are 0 then the errors we get
zeroes and of course we cannot get zero
errors so you're saying sign around of
PI over two
, point six or something oh well
interesting okay so so we can do have
some heuristics and and as I said I'm
sure the univariate case can be solved
the problem is the multivariate case
with correlation that I have no idea how
to attack but you see ultimately this is
kind of I don't know I'm the immediate
analogy that's coming to mind maybe cuz
I'm thinking about other things is
computing Hawking radiation using
quantum field theory around a classical
black hole I mean we've got we've got
two different kinds of approximations
going on here and it's it's some I mean
I think it it may be just undoable
because it may be that yes you can do
the exact symbolic computation but as
soon as you throw yourself into this
kind of calculus of error propagations
it's just a different thing I'm not sure
it's going to work to try and combine
those why do you think that this sort of
symbolic limiting is going to be doable
I mean what I do you think this is not
gonna get totally tangled up with things
where we're for example here's the case
that I would think is going to go wrong
you have a case where it's sort of an
in-your-face symbolic limit issue like
the case of this unit step function fine
you can deal with that
what about if it creeps up on you by a
series of a hundred computations you can
know that if you were to do it
symbolically you know there's some limit
to what can come out but in a series of
a hundred computations just following
the error propagation calculus you don't
see that see what I'm saying
I mean cannot happen I don't know if
that can happen I I think that has to be
able to happen I mean can't I make this
thing into some kind of sigmoid or
something where it's like not so
obviously you know let's say this is a
thing which is a hyperbolic arctangent
right so that it doesn't precisely
I guess that still has a an asymptotic
value but something where there's a very
slow increase as we go out here
right I could invent something with a
very very slow increase and then you
know do I really when the actual limits
are plus minus infinity because the
thing has you know but it's really
really far out and chances are with an
around you know near the center that you
don't want to go out to that asymptotic
you know log log n growth rate type
thing I'm suspicious about whether this
is possible and and the only question is
could we perhaps detect that something
went wrong and generate a message or
some such other thing and then what do
we tell people to do well these things
are Indian effectively some sort of
transform distribution which is very
complicated integral so I guess some
sort of Monte Carlo method could be a
generic solution but it becomes I think
it can be a bit but I mean what we know
already because we you know we have ways
of just propagating exact probability
distributions through operations and we
know that what happens there is the
distribution gets incredibly fragmented
incredibly quickly and you know it is
completely computationally infeasible to
track every detail of every wiggle of
the distribution as it's gone through
five operations or something and the
whole point of this calculus of error
propagation is you avoid that issue you
just say everything sort of roughly
approximated by a Gaussian and there is
a well-defined calculus of propagating
the errors um
and I'm just this requires more thought
I think look I think what we should do
here um have you talked to I don't know
who's the most relevant I mean it's both
robbed on the numerix side and Adam
maybe on the algebra side I think this
probably deserves a separate kind of
more math oriented meeting to discuss no
there isn't
I think we can fairly say there is no
obvious solution I mean this is one of
these things where you know it's like
saying we're doing machine precision
arithmetic great there are cases where
machine precision arithmetic
fail it's hard to tell when that's going
to happen and you know the effort to
tell when that's going to happen is you
know triple the computational work and
if you want to be sure it isn't gonna
happen well don't use machinery stick
use you know arbitrary-precision
arithmetic where we're checking all
those things but I think this is this
might be the same type of take case if
you're gonna use automatic error
propagation then the pathological cases
will not be covered and and there's just
nothing we can do about it I mean you
know this this case here is yeah I mean
you know that's the life of calculus or
something I mean this is just it's not
um I don't really know what you I mean
what do you expect this to do you expect
this to use the interval computation
where you know that um I mean because
this is working to first order right
that's that's why it's giving you this
result exactly yeah
so they're totally horizontal and it's
giving you a very smaller so this is a
case in which the second order
approximation approximation but I mean
you can make me the n floor
approximation because I'm gonna give you
something which is you know whether the
first n derivatives are all zero never
gonna be able to win that um well it's
an interesting problem I mean I'm look I
think it needs if there's gonna be a
solution it is not going to be purely a
mathematical solution it's going to be a
solution that is a combination of
messaging when we know something has
gone wrong even defining what it means
to go wrong because you know yeah I mean
the question is we were pretty careful
to not define that that around is a
Gaussian distribution because you know
it just isn't in you know it's not the
way it works okay there's that there's a
question here about whether if we
specify a confidence level will the
confidence level propagate through
computations in other words does the
around no so you can specify a
confidence level in input it will be
converted into a normal around
the computation will proceed and then if
you want to show it again you need to
use our own form well so we could also
say we could also have some option to
around which says what I'm you know I am
representing the two Sigma level rather
than the one Sigma level and then it
could automatically come out in output
because I mean in a sense okay so then
the obvious question is what's the
calculus of combining arounds if you if
you have an around that's the one Sigma
around plus and around that's the two
sigma around what do you do right so I
have explicitly try to avoid that
following numbers and quantities so
trying to separate the mathematical
content from the display content I think
it's going to become really complicated
if we try to merge okay but let's take
the following question okay
let's imagine that you've got a two
Sigma around that's given an input
though in your interpretation that this
is all gaussians what you should do is
to you know have the value have the
Delta and stick it in as the one Sigma
you know is around X plus or minus Delta
and then say oh by the way this was
supposed to be displayed as a to Sigma
around so upon display show to Delta
rather than just Delta and that's the
way you could do it now the problem is
what happens if you say a 1 Sigma around
plus a 2 Sigma around what do you do in
other words who wins the display what do
you think what what would the right
answer to that be I mean in other words
a very weird case would be a single one
Sigma around plus a bunch of 3 Sigma
around what should win the display I
think there should be some canonical
1:31 see
okay but if they're all three Sigma what
should it do we might preserve Sigma but
anyway I'm not that means we would have
a different result for a round form of a
round plus a round form of around I'm
not sure that's the right thing it's for
the question is is it important to be
able to say I mean it's important at the
end it's for typesetting when you are
going to present your result in an
article you will worry about which
confidence levels to show it but you
don't care about it yes um well fair
enough fair enough I mean I think it's
it's a little weird that's that's one of
the very few cases where you would have
a a typesetting wrapper that seems to
have sort of mathematical significance
but actually has no effect on the
internal structure well imagine for
example that we give errors or all as
percentages does that mean that we want
the error back as percentage to
hmm I don't know how do you give the
errors as percentages you drove the
scale right in input in our scale but we
don't have right now a way of presenting
the result as 30% and in some areas like
with resistances and things like that
they typically give errors with
percentages okay so you're saying that a
round form would have the possibility of
getting a percentage error and your
point is that just because you entered
it in percentage form doesn't mean you
necessarily wants to come out in
percentage form well just like I mean it
well what happens in the case of numbers
there are cases where you can enter it
in some oh it doesn't care whether I
entered the thing as you know star wedge
3 it still just gives me that okay all
right let's try and just have a quick
look at some of these other things here
um definitely okay then on our live
stream is making a comment yeah
data set
exporting
there is that as an excel file does not
come out correctly like it does with a
CSV file oh that's interesting
should I mean in other words a data set
that is of the right depth to be
exported as an excel file because excel
at least in the current time future
might be different doesn't doesn't
support higher depth tables I think it's
just a bug bit maybe you can propagate
that to shorty and hurt people
yes sure okay oh good yes so there are
several projects going on with dataset
and the first two are the most important
ones in my opinion and and then of
course we need to improve documentation
and Chris is going to be working now on
having better more predictable they
layout sometimes with data set you just
try to see what's going to do right look
I think that they um yeah this is really
important if we can get that to work is
that an active project now right well be
great to get that I mean that project
was almost finished several years ago
and never really got connected in um
look I think to my mind the big thing to
figure out what data set is how to make
it easier to use um I mean it is it is a
you know it's basically high art of
functional programming right now to do
sophisticated things with it and yes
people find that quite difficult and the
question is whether we can provide user
assistance capabilities with Auto
completions and things like this to help
that or whether we can use natural
language or whether there's a different
idea and I think we should try it what
we should probably do is get a meeting
where we've got a bunch of examples of
data set queries and try to understand
what it would take to make those easier
for people to to enter maybe maybe Chris
could assemble that you know just a
collection of like
50 data set queries ok been on our live
stream um it is commenting with just the
Titanic data set fails to export
properly to Excel go to feed that to
show this group and get an answer to
that that sounds horrible
okay quickly here yeah more axiomatic
systems I think that would be nice I
mean we have that student who is
interested in working on that I think
that's something to do there I would say
um I mean in terms of clearly that's a
much more niche thing than data set but
it's something will be nice to see move
forward more groups given by relations
so I mean the current way of
representing a group by relations to me
is completely non computable right I
mean if I say finite group data to give
me a group what's a good group
icosahedral group all right what do I
say here okay so I mean that's
magnificent but not very computable
right and that's why now we have this
way of getting it via axiomatic theory
how do you do that so with the economic
theory list group actions Carmichael
Bureau that doesn't also complete
somebody should report that oh so these
are the same but expressed and you can
also say with an association the
multiplication speed they you need
element is so you can control the heads
what's the thing I was trying to do
recently for which this was um I think I
had my my home made Cayley Graaf
generator that I was trying to use
something like this on yes but now of
course going from these relations to the
group itself is very complicated we're
gonna have the functionality to do this
that's this is that the cod coxeter
business or something or what is that
yes that's part of it but to go in other
words if I just write down a random set
of generators and Relations you're
saying most of the time it's really hard
to figure out what's equivalent to what
I mean aren't you ultimately having to
solve the word problem somehow yes and
in fact given a set of relations you
know even if their group is finite for
example sure I mean actually I was
interested in ones that weren't finite
and I was interested in the Cayley
graphs of non finite groups um and yeah
I mean right I in fact I put in the
function repository this homegrown Kayla
graph generator with it with its an el
cheapo word problem solver um okay
there's a question here on a live stream
from Peter will will the lattice of
subgroups be added in a finite group
data a reasonable suggestion so if I say
here subgroups yeah I mean the other
thing we really have got to do is to
make these symbolic rather than just
these weird 'less things this is a
notation that always I know that I know
that because this was built a long time
ago um I mean I think it's time for us
to do something more symbolic perhaps
use entities perhaps use I mean I maybe
we can't use entities because these are
parameterized like you have the cyclic
group of 60 elements or something we I
think you do entity of group comma
entity finite comma one of these it
works already so if I say what were you
saying if I say entity yeah but so if I
bet if I say alternating group of 57
or something here Wow what happens if I
say I mean what happens if I say
something like this huh one thing final
group later is Abel will try honestly to
compute things a Maitre it may take a
long time the entity framework has some
predefined data and it will tell you
immediately no I don't have that case so
sorry so if I say this and then I say
something like Kayla graph of that but
if I say Kayla graph of this you're
saying that will work fine a group data
of alternate a group six comma Kayla
graph why doesn't this work what does
Kayla graph usually eat as an argument
it has a symbolic notation so it's we
have alternating group of bracket six
okay so that's what I'm complaining
about that I'm complaining that these
things should be turned into that
symbolic form maybe we can define that
as a project I mean that doesn't seem
super difficult um beautiful right so
the so final coordinator handles many
more groups that we have in symbolic
form because in symbolic form we have
right now the ones that we can handle be
a permutation groups many of the groups
in Faneuil group theta are groups that
naturally are given via matrix groups
yes roughly type and brothers have
representation symbolic representation
follows right okay
all right quick quickly going through
some of these other things alright so
there's there's some some things to be
done here I think we should investigate
whether some of these interns slash
students are relevant for this um dates
oh yeah I'll be very happy to see it is
this in 12.1 the new typesetting it's
not in 12.1 there's still some
additional work being done on it but
it's basically ready to go we just need
to get the final design sign-off okay
but that will be nice yeah
date array yeah we kind of know that
date select ha we haven't talked about
that design have we we've talked about a
little bit there's a futurist ref page I
know we need to wrap up here but
basically the idea is to use parameters
you can have from date value as a
selection criteria so you could specify
holidays like that or say you know I
want October 14th on odd years or you
know basically supply arbitrary criteria
and they neither specify a select list
of dates or a date interval and be able
to do sub selection from there right
okay calendars yeah young Christopher
was just doing something on some
Babylonian calendar which apparently is
which basically is just tabula because
it depended on when you know when some
Babylonian king decided to reset things
and so on but how many how far are we
gonna go with calendar um how far are we
gonna go with these counters and what
are we gonna do in cases where well go
on you were going to say we have
collected of the order of 40 or 50 and
it's just a matter of sorting them in
the order of priority and having
somebody okay
I did notice that a natural language
stuff I was looking at um okay the thing
I was looking at was something very
weird
but a little it's not I'll tell you what
it was it was funny okay what is that
what on earth is that what on earth is
that okay okay so I think this
what happened maybe oh oh that's because
that came up and then that that's the
wrong behavior condemning can you report
that as a bug yes okay see that should
not immediately just decide that it is
group Orion extrapolated Gregorian dates
that's wrong it should it should have an
assuming their um the um okay who wants
to know why I was trying to figure out
that date nobody because it turns out
there's a character called Saint Wolfram
believe it or not ah no relation who
lived in 703 ad and I was trying to work
out I had just was trying to work out
the feast day of Saint Wolfram but it
was all confused because it isn't even
clear what year he lived died whatever
but anyway that was that was how I ended
up with that date um it was an extremely
minor Saint I would say um anyway um
okay quantum computing were actually
just about to do and people who are on
this live stream might be interested in
that in about 15 minutes we are going to
be doing a discussion about quantum
computing so that is coming there trees
is now underway is that a correct
statement the compiler version of a data
structure trees that's got to be very
useful to do operations so there are now
the three worlds of what Chevy all
started with three element the graph
version and the compiler version so it's
going to be interesting too I hope with
a good definition of the word
interesting okay alright Combinator's
finally we've talked about several times
I mean the real issue with combinators
it's a whole story of evaluation I mean
look it will be nice to do something
this is the centenary of Combinator's it
would be really nice to be able to do
something with those you know the issue
as we keep on discussing is evaluation
and I mean strangely really strangely
that dovetails as you know with the you
know my physics project which ultimately
is all about the relationship between
reference frames and evaluation orders
and we should understand something you
know we should have a sort of profound
new understanding of what it means to do
concurrent computing in and what it
means to do different kinds of valuation
orders as a result of kind of the
parameterization of frames but we don't
yet have that I mean it'll be quite
amusing I mean I think we'll get things
that are the analog of you know various
kinds of coordinate systems and so on
that represent different essentially
evaluation fronts in in one of these
systems and I think that's a I mean
that's a that's a super interesting
direction but it is definitely high
science math computer science whatever
you call it to solve that um and that's
kind of what we need to do culminate as
well um okay it's a comment from
Mohammed on our livestream that data set
gets cropped in the new windows front
end that's upsetting to hear somebody
check into that yep okay we've got to
wrap it up um good well that's where we
should be back on on track for doing
these ILD meetings I hope and for those
on this livestream as I say at half past
the hour roughly we'll be talking about
quantum computing and thanks to
everybody here thanks people on the
livestream and um see y'all soon